docteur chrétiens merci de nous
accueillir dans votre laboratoire
la mesure est ce que c'est possible que
vous votre équipe allait contribuer à
trouver le médicament contre le corps
n'avait reçu sa défense se sont vidés si
ça fonctionne pas au moins on a essayé
mais ça des gens de fonctionner et c'est
tellement grave c'est une pandémie
maintenant qu' il faut il faut faire
quelque chose et nous on n'y a désormais
ce blouson ce qu'on sait et on a fait
des expériences crucial avec le
laboratoire national de microbiologie de
winnipeg qui étaient les seuls capables
de manipuler les ebola qui quiconque de
prouver ils ont beaucoup de succès non
seulement pour guérir mais pour prévenir
donc il agit à deux niveaux ce qui a
fait peut-être un candidat meilleur qu
un antiviral pur donc ç'a bien
fonctionné pour les mollahs ou là et
d'asie quand on a fait la musique
si ça fonctionne bien pour le
coronavirus combien de temps ça prendra
avant que le commun des mortels puisse
prendre
lazare fait qu'on en est à cape town
publie nous nos résultats des compagnies
pharmaceutiques petites combines
pharmaceutique dessus ce qui vend des
médias marquons trois rats dont la
cotation avait fait tout le travail
disons de préparer d'un contretemps à
haute dose et il a fait approuver par
mail par le fbi américain
donc on a on a quelqu'un qui est victime
qui a des millions de fidèles à sa
disposition et qu'il émet actuellement
qu'une enquête avec tout dedans
l'actuel pour donner à la chaîne des
médicaments nécessaires non les à six
sont dans les pilules existent ont été
produites
pourquoi est-ce que vous c'est vous
partez avec des caisses de pileux vers
la chine ça ce soir on va décider ouais
ce midi en conférence téléphonique avec
notre collègue de sus d'accompagner pour
lui demander le nom d' comme le mil
suffisant pour faire un essai clinique
sur le total de mes les malades qui va
demander 100 moines haiwan qui va
demander à peu près 120 mg comprimé ces
quatre pages aux patients et on à la
mode avec capable de livrer des six
semaines et vous y allez vous allez vous
rendre là peut-être pas mais avec les
moyens techniques modernes de
communication on va établir et c'est une
sage une salle de communication
permanente par vidéo pour être en
contact 24 padoue avec les chinois parce
que les résultats ou êtes rappeler à
tous les jours ici ça fonctionne si
d'ici quelques semaines on voit des
effets bénéfiques
la petite entreprise pharmaceutique vont
pouvoir vendre sur la planète ou quoi
c'est sur un an au début donné ça pour
les malades atteints de atteint 2
de quoi rendre le virus n'a pas oublié
les brûler
au congo où on est impliqué aussi donc
ça c'est en février deux cibles
premières disons à utiliser destin qui
disons comprimé et il dit ce qui permet
à fable que beaucoup le court 10 ans
pour donner au reste du monde
si vous voulez mais ça va prendre
beaucoup beaucoup de comprimés on parle
de l'heure le comblement et s'ils
s'avéraient positifs tant mieux on tout
le monde applaudit est ce que
l'entreprise pharmaceutique va faire une
fortune comment ça va fonctionner ce qui
rend sa misère côtoie donc c'est presque
pas brevetable par jour par patient
alors que les nouveaux antiviraux qui se
disait que cela coûte 1000 dollars par
jour cette plante là pour n'importe où
il ya dans plusieurs dans la grisaille
on a là et dans la cadre à la manne
engagé plusieurs cantillon de grande
concentration de bonne concentration de
cossette inc
sauf que 90 des j'accepte ans et pas
assez concentrés nous les discussions
qu'on a eues c'était de présente dos qui
se révélèrent donc beaucoup plus élevé
on ne vérifie ces éléments c'était
toxique c'est l'image que le trailer
cela allait beaucoup
donc on a testé bingo excusez le terme
et cette sulfureuse tout ça renforce le
système immunitaire
les deux ça à ccc préventifs et curatifs
investis qui se serait en plus on peut
en cultiver dans daddah candidat de la
course est à nouveau mais c'est un pas
mais qu'on danse il y avait 10 et
graveleux msj pandémie comment vous
qualifier ce qui se passe comment vous
comparez ce de jour en jour de toutes
les nouvelles
en me levant le matin de monado c'est de
pire en pire et avec ce matin des
nouvelles de ce matin la corde et qui
est en état d'urgence
le nord britannique est fermé ça
correspond à la définition de la
pandémie par ces sur deux continents et
des pandémies et ne pollue beaucoup la
mode en dalles talent
alors faut s'appeler un peu de la grippe
espagnole on n'était pas dans la salle
mais c'est que ça se répandait comme un
fait pour des millions et des millions
de 50 à 100 millions de marks était trop
mal à 5% de la population
est ce que les chinois terminent en
docteur chrétiens collaborent bien sont
ouverts vous ouvre les portes
on est loin de la politique en ont deux
canadiens emprisonnés là oui ça peut
aider à tous il est incroyable c'est
plein d est aussi le pourrait mais la
réponse d'achat ça fait quatre semaines
compte à compte qu'ils ont vécu et ce
matin on me dit aaron va calmer les
protocoles
aujourd'hui on veut ravir un chinois et
zhu cheng qui est menacé de laisser su
celui qui pilote où elle aide aussi la
boîte et d'un assène nous l'a 16 élèves
qu'ai je vois des déportés lui même ou
me dise pas ce que c'est dans ces médias
santé donc notre collaborateur là bas
qui pointent vers la mecque et en
cherchant un sur elle sur les cancers
sur les du simi a mis à mal a pas
déduire on vous invite occupe de vous et
à tous les 24 heures du fonds disait
c'est incroyable que j'ai jamais connu à
quatre semaines journée d'efforts même
pour un milliard de personnes
saisis sont efficaces comme j'ai jamais
vu quoi y'a donc la filière de
l'institut pourraient faire en sorte que
c'est la filière destitue me soutiennent
et venise et les années 80 avec sa femme
enfin ça y est on est on est quand on
est un ami depuis ce temps là et il ya
même vu
docteur honoris causa de cette mort ya
huit ans vous allez devenir le nouveau
docteur bitume on a besoin d'améliorer
nos relations avec les chinoises c'est
pour créer un scudetto nom d'acteur
chrétien on va on se croise les doigts
pour vrai plus que vous que l'on désire
votre intuition et la bonne année à
toute votre équipe
les lots pour servir espérons que ça
vous dit quelque chose qu'on n'a rien à
perdre puisque la clé et mondial la clé
très sérieuses de ne pas d'ennemis qui
se répand comme ça comme a fait part de
sa faveur
dr chrétien on nous souhaite le mieux ou
ce soin de moi je souhaite ni parce
qu'on se procure même
merci beaucoup plus imprécis